なので
みんなコーラ好きでしょねまま寝たくちゃんがねフォーラスフィア分
今日はねえって見直しのためにねコーラがてるね蛇口をね作ろうと思うんだよね
おふざけここまでだ俺を夢の橋の作っなんですよ
玉座月からひねってさあコーラが出るってさぁみんな揺れだと思うんだよなぁ今日
実際に作ってみようと思います
ています
準備するようなねーまずは耐圧ホースを蛇口
バスポンプこのテープにコーラを入れて本当はここに入ってってコーラを吸い上げて
全部力コーヒーて出すみたいなにょねまぁ実際に作ってみましょう夏直感くるなぁと
思ってもらっ
プレゼン時に放送つけましょうこれ昔から
夢だったんだよねもういつも水道課が出る行きたいば透明なものばかり
あっ取りつっ
[音楽]
使う記号まつげなく間違っちゃったら全然くっつかないもこれウにで絶対つかないよ粉
を混ぜて言ってんの
抜き本作っちのできなかったらさあちょっとヤバいんだけど
今後の youtube 生活に支障が出るくらいやる気が長くなくなる
復帰と1本文
イサキ桜咲く人生では言い訳なんてっていうかなぁホースと在留2月投げ合いて何も
始まらないことが分かった
これとこれが本当にくっ使う
[音楽]
これでよくねー
大活躍島はしてもし今子供これオンにしてここに入れるとここから出てくるといい
でしょ
チーム電源断を知名度アップへ全員名坊
その違いでもついたほど電源だ俺ダメだこっちれちゃった分山終って ok をニャン
ダーさんだったさんとこれでこうすると
[音楽]
奴隷舌の言えばいいもあるん
たなんとかできました大須とこれがつなげたんねぇ
ポンプで口論巻き上げてるんでもう少々お待ちください
いろいろ試したんですけど
家内からだけでを
どうにもならないこともありは多分ポンパの力が弱いんだとターンさんだからこう
うまいことホース2コーナーが来なくて
を
ん
おっ
ユン
[音楽]
ん
ブー
[音楽]
goo ん
内海ズっていうの高いとこから落ちてくるんで一応これで落ちてきているはずなので
ひねれば出ると思いますでは行けますかなります
[音楽]
あっいやっおっしゃってるんですよね
もう一つてる
[音楽]
みちゃんだ
バーってチャまぜてひねったら出るんですよ
頃
べっちゃべちゃだけでいいやと言うぞ
web 増者
こういう固定とかったらもう完全にも旧帝はですからねうん
出てるよぉっ出てるよ
お子様やご標準って言う訳ねー
あの
実用的ではありませんん
[音楽]
持っています